Me encantan los árboles, y tengo mucha suerte
porque vivimos cerca de un magnífico jardín botánico,
y los domingos, usualmente solíamos ir con mi esposa
y ahora con mi hija de cuatro años,
y trepábamos a los árboles y jugábamos a las escondidas.
La segunda escuela a la que fui también tenía grandes árboles,
tenía un tulípero fantástico, creo que era el más grande del país,
y, también, tenía muchos arbustos y vegetación magníficos
alrededor, alrededor de los campos de juego.
Y un día, me agarraron algunos de mis compañeros,
me llevaron a los arbustos, me desvistieron, me atacaron,
fui abusado, y esto ocurrió de la nada.
Bien, la razón por la que digo esto, es porque después pensaba...
bien, regresé a la escuela, me sentía sucio, me sentía traicionado,
me sentía avergonzado, pero, principalmente, me sentía impotente,
y 30 años después estaba sentado en un avión,
al lado de una señora llamada Verónica, que era de Chile,
y estábamos en una gira por los derechos humanos,
y ella había comenzado a contarme cómo era ser torturado,
y, desde mi posición de privilegio,
este fue el único punto de referencia que tenía.
Y fue una experiencia de aprendizaje asombrosa
porque, para mí, los derechos humanos era algo en lo que tenía,
saben, un interés de tiempo parcial, pero sobre todo
era algo que le ocurría a otra gente allí afuera.
Pero recibí una llamada de Bono en 1985 y, como saben,
es un gran cantante, pero un magnífico activista, y...
(Risas)
es un tipo al que es difícil decirle no, y me decía
saben, justo después haber hecho la canción de Biko,
que íbamos a hacer la gira de Amnistía,
tenés que estar en él, y, en realidad, esa fue la primera vez
que salía y comenzaba a conocer personas
que habían visto matar a su familia delante de ellos,
y que tenían un compañero a quien habían arrojado al océano,
y de repente, este mundo de los derechos humanos llegó a mi mundo,
y no pude, realmente, alejarme tal como lo había hecho antes.
Y entonces me involucré con la gira para Amnistía,
y luego, en el 88 me hice cargo del trabajo de Bono e intenté aprender cómo movilizar
No lo hice tan bien, pero logré juntar a Youssou N'Dour, Sting,
Tracy Chapman y Bruce Springsteen para dar la vuelta al mundo por Amnistía,
y fue una experiencia asombrosa.
Y, una vez más, obtuve una extraordinaria enseñanza,
y fue la primera vez, en realidad,
que conocería gente en diferentes países,
y estas historias de derechos humanos se corporizaron,
y una vez más, no pude, realmente, alejarme con comodidad.
Pero lo que realmente me sorprendió, sobre lo que no tenía idea,
fue que se podía sufrir de ese modo